voici tout ce qui change en France à
partir du 1er octobre 2023 première info
les soins dentaires seront moins
remboursés la part de l'assurance
maladie va passer de 70 à 60%. il faut
désormais payer 3 euros pour une
livraison de livres à domicile il s'agit
d'une mesure pour soutenir les libraires
indépendants face à la concurrence
d'Amazon notamment cela concerne les
livraisons en dessous de 35 €. il y aura
désormais moins de sel dans les
baguettes de pain il s'agit d'une mesure
prise pour abaisser notre consommation
de sel qui serait trop importante
d'après l'Organisation mondiale de la
santé la location adulte handicapé sera
désormais calculée de façon individuelle
seul le bénéficiaire et ses ressources
personnelles seront prises en compte
dans le calcul de la prestation et
bénéficiaires de l'appel verront leur
aide augmenter de 3,5%. et ce mois
d'octobre marque aussi le passage à
l'heure d'hiver dans la nuit du 28 au 29
octobre on enlèvera une heure il fera
donc nuit une heure plus tôt comme tu le
sais on t'informe chaque jour sur brut
alors abonne-toi à notre compte pour
suivre l'actualité à bientôt